hi I'm Nick butcher and engineer on the
Android developer relations team and I'm
going to show you a quick trick for your
activity animations so by default when
you switch screens Android will show an
animation between those two screens a
slight variation on the standard
animation is using a grow up grow down
animation which helps you to retain some
context where the users come from you
might be familiar with this from the
recent animation but you can use it in
your own app so here for example I have
a grid layout and if I touch on one of
these tiles like this top right one
it'll grow up from where I touched and
if I go from around here it will grow
from there so it helps to retain context
I've slowed this animation down using
one of the tricks using warmer settings
and developer options called transition
animation scale just to demonstrate this
better if I turn that off and go back
you'll see it's pretty subtle but it
really does help remember where the user
came from best of all this is incredibly
easy for you to do in your code so here
we are I'm creating a bitmap to scale
from so here it's just a simple color
for my demo and then you just use the
static method on activity options to
call make scale-up animation and passing
it the view to scale from the bitmap
thumbnail to scale from and it will
return you a bundle you pass this bundle
to your call to start activity and this
will perform the animation for you
couldn't be easier one slight variation
or I should have commented out here you
can see in the code is to scale up just
from review without the thumbnail option
so if you don't have a thumbnail to
scale from this is a slightly different
you'll have to do a fade animation as
well as the grow animations you have a
slightly different effect but if you
don't have a thumbnail to scale from you
can use this thanks very much